موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال مراسل الجزيره
ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اعترضت اهدافا
جويه فوق مدينه بيلو قرود الروسيه للمره
الثانيه يوم امس وقال حاكم المقاطعه ان
الدفاعات الجويه تعاملت مع ثلاثه اهداف
فوق المدينه ومحيطها
بدوره قال الناطق باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان قوته دمرت ثمان دبابات لبارد
المانيه صنع يقاتل بها الاوكرانيون في ان
التشكيلات الروسيه احبطت جميع محاولات
القوات الاوكرانيه للتقدم في محور دونيتس
من جانبها قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب في القوات الاوكرانيه ان
عجز روسيا عن معرفه اتجاه الهجوم المضاد
يبقي الجيش الروسي متاهبا ويدفعه للتحرك
في اماكن عده
بدوره قال نائب المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الموقف الروسي في
ساحه الحرب الاوكرانيه ضعيف داعيا
للكرملين الى سحب قواته من اوكرانيا اذا
كان يريد ايقاف خسائره هناك على حد تعبيره
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ان الوكاله ركبت لاول مره اجهزه
مراقبه للتخصيب في منشات
الايرانيتين واضاف ان الوكاله لم تخفف
معاييرها في الرقابه على المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه
من جهته قال مسؤول ايراني للجزيره ان
تقرير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه يثبت
ان طهران تفضل دائما التعاون مع الوكاله
المسؤول الايراني يعبر عن استعداد بلاده
الوقف سياسه خفض الالتزام ببنود الاتفاق
النووي شرط التزام الاخرين بالاتفاق
وفي واشنطن قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيين
جميع الخيارات ستكون مطروحه على الطاوله
لمنع ايران من الحصول على سلاح نووي حاله
رفضها المسار الدبلوماسي
في السودان افاد مراسل الجزيره بتجدد
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
في مدن العاصمه الثلاث الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري واندرمان وافاد مراسلنا بسماع اصوات
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله في مناطق عده
غربيه الخرطوم
وقالت مصادر عسكريه في الجيش السوداني
للجزيره ان قوات الجيش سيطرت على شارع
الاربعين في ام درمان بالعاصمه الخرطوم
هذا واعلنت قوات الدعم السريع سيطرتها على
حاميه عسكريه في مدينه كوتوم غربيه البلاد
وهو ما نفاه الجيش
تتواصل احتجاجات صرب كوسوفو في محيط مقر
ثلاث بلديه شماليه البلاد مطالبين بعدم
دخول رؤساء المجالس المحليه الجدد اليها
وكانت قوات حفظ السلام الدوليه ازالت
الجزء الاكبر من الاسلاك الشائكه في محيط
مبنى بلديه
هذا واجتمع رئيس وزراء كوسوفو مع كل من
مبعوث الاتحاد الاوروبي للحوار بين كوسوفو
وصربيا والمبعوث الامريكي الى غرب البلقاء
لبحث ايجاد حل الوضع المتوتري شمال كوسو
عقب الانتخابات البلديه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]